let's return to our fairly simple
banking example and see if we can use it
to actually understand or at least get a
better idea of what money is and how
it's created so in the original example
i said let's see let me get my pen tool
right i said you know i have this idea i
have all of these farmers who at the end
of the season they sell all of their
apples let's say that's the main cash
crop on on on our island
and so they and then every year they
just have this you know collectively
they have i'll just make up a number a
thousand gold pieces that they get
or at least this year i'll call it a
thousand gold
right they have a thousand gold coins
that they get at the end of the year
normally the farmers just kind of stash
it under their mattresses or
or kind of dig up a hole and put it
there and i say boy you know what a
waste because they're actually good
projects out there that people could be
maybe irrigation ditches factories
whatever else a tool factory anything
else but there's just no money for those
people to build those things if only
somehow i could take this money and use
it for those projects then we would
actually create wealth we'd have
innovation and our entire pie would get
bigger so what i do is i
start up this bank and i'll do i'll do
it all over again just like i did last
time
let's say that i have
i don't know i personally had 100 gold
pieces
i'm going to stick with gold because i
want to show you how the money creation
there is a small multiplier effect even
when you're using gold some people think
it only happens with paper money this is
all a byproduct of the fact fractional
reserve system which was
essentially what i showed you in the
last two videos but let's just go
through the whole example so i take a
hundred gold pieces and i
construct this nice vault looking
building
right so this is real estate
or
building and it's worth 100 100 gold
these are my assets
assets on the left-hand side liabilities
on the right-hand side and then i go
tell all of these farmers i was like one
your money's not safe there and if you
actually keep it as a deposit in my nice
looking building i will give you
interest on it so those farmers say
great idea so they all deposit their
thousand gold pieces into my bank
so now i have this liability that i have
a thousand gold pieces liability
and why is it a liability because i owe
it to the farmers they at some point in
the future they're going to come back to
me and say hey you know that gold i gave
you i want it back so it's a liability
to me but it's also an asset on my side
right but my whole business model is i
wanted to put this to work so what i do
is i put some aside so essentially i
make some reserves i'll do the reserves
in red because we're going to want to
we're going to want to pay attention to
them later let's say i put 10 percent
aside
so i put 100 gold pieces aside
i do that in case any of those farmers
the next day or the next week come to me
and say oh you know what i actually need
my money i need to um you know my my my
son needs a haircut or whatever the need
might be but anyway i put a hundred gold
pieces aside as reserves and then the
remainder so this
gold pieces
i lend out let me do that in a different
color i'll do it in green
900 gold pieces i lend out so it's an
asset but the gold is gone i take that
gold this is 900 gold remember i had a
thousand gold pieces come in i kept 100
of it and now i'm going to lend it to
someone who has a really good project so
say
normally you would lend it to a bunch of
people but for the sake of simplicity
let's say i lend it to someone who has
an irrigation project
he's going to take that 900 gold pieces
and pay a bunch of
people who are probably not doing
anything anymore because the apple crop
has been harvested and sold
and they're going to build an irrigation
canal so that more land is is usable to
make more apples the next year and i say
that's a great investment because
they're going to make more apples or
they're going to sell the water to the
farmers and they should be able to pay
some interest to me right
so i give my 900 gold pieces to them to
build the to essentially dig these
ditches
well the 900 gold pieces that then goes
to the workers right
the borrower borrowed them and then paid
it to the workers
900 gold goes to the workers
and so after the project is done you
have a bunch of workers with
900 gold pieces right
well these workers they're just like the
farmers they say well you know i don't
want to put it in my bed and i want to
get interest on it and it's not safe
inside my house so let's say that my
bank is the only game in town so they go
back to my bank and they say hey
bank of sal
i want to deposit my money with you and
i say great so what i do is i take their
900 gold pieces and i take it as a
deposit so let me try to draw that as a
deposit
so i take their
nine i'm going to try to see if this is
a thousand 900 might be about that
900 gold pieces
so this is this is the farmer's deposits
right that was kind of the initial money
so then i get the 900 gold pieces from
the workers
i want to make this as neat as possible
but i didn't want to go through the pain
of having multiple banks because you
could you could do this with just one
bank maybe in a future video i'll do it
with multiple banks just to show you
that all the deposits don't have to go
to one place but it's the same idea
anyway so these 900 gold pieces are
essentially deposited back into my bank
for safe keeping and i say boy you know
i don't need to keep all of this 900
all of this 900 gold pieces here i could
lend it out again for some useful
project so once again i say well you
know these are demand deposits which
means that these farmers could demand
them at any time
so let me put a little bit aside i know
statistically that no more than
maybe 10 percent of them will come in a
given day so let me set aside 10 percent
of that so i'll once again i'll have 10
reserves so i'll set aside
90 gold
pieces set aside 90 gold pieces and then
the other
let me do that in the lending color
the other 810
gold pieces i lend out and let's say i
lend it out to some entrepreneur and
remember i'm getting interest in all of
this but we're not concerned with the
interest right now we're concerned with
the money supply so i lend it out to
some guy who wants to build a factory
build a factory for cutting tools
that'll help all of us become more
productive when we have to harvest our
apples or maybe even digging the ditches
so build factory build factory
so once again
this 810
gold pieces they're going to go to the
construction workers or the contractors
who built the factory so let's call it
you know factory contractors the people
who
factory contractors the people who build
the factory
contractors
well once again now they have 810 gold
pieces and they're like wow i don't like
keeping it in my house there's that nice
fancy vault that sal has and he gives
interest on it so they take those 810
gold pieces and they deposit it in my
bank
so they take those 810 gold pieces and
deposit it in my bank
and then i could continue well let's
just say that i could i could just
continue this process so forth and so on
and just so you know it doesn't it
doesn't go infinitely right because
every step of the way we're having a
little bit less and you can i'll do the
little i'll do the fancier math on how
to figure out how many steps we can do
but let's just make let's just stop it
there just for the sake of brevity and
just so i don't run out of space on this
so they take 810 gold pieces and i kind
of for the most part feel that i've lent
enough money out there so i keep all of
this 810 gold pieces as reserves
so
i don't lend that out although i could i
could just set aside 10 percent of it 81
gold pieces and then lend the rest of it
out but i don't do that i just put i
just keep all of those 810 gold pieces
as reserved so this is my balance sheet
after you know maybe if these if these
transactions occur all at once over the
course of the year this is what the bank
of sales balance sheet looks like these
are my assets and these are my
liabilities and notice assets
are still equal to liabilities plus
equity this was equity
equity this is liabilities right these
are deposits that people that i owe to
people deposits
equal liabilities
from a bank point of view they're assets
for those people
liabilities and then these are my assets
some of them are cash money right in
magenta these this 810 this 90 this 100.
this is these are gold coins that are
sitting in my vault so that's definitely
an asset that i have and then these are
loans that i lent well at least this and
this these are loans that i lent out to
somebody and that's an asset as long as
they pay me back
so now we have set it all up my question
to you is how much money is there in the
system or in our economy
so it all depends how you define money
so let's make a definition let's say i
define
i make a definition called m0
and this is just how much gold is there
right how much gold
in the system well we can go and count
it right
well notice all the gold is being held
in my bank so we just have to go to this
one bank and count how much gold it has
it has 100 gold here
90 gold here 810 gold here so if you're
810 plus 90 plus 100 is equal to a
thousand gold
so there's a thousand gold pieces
and that makes sense right because we
had a thousand gold pieces to begin with
and we didn't mine for any new gold or
we didn't turn any
i don't know low we didn't use any load
stones to turn lead into gold or
anything like that we we just had the
original thousand gold pieces and
there's no way to create more they don't
reproduce on their own so we still have
a thousand gold pieces and we can kind
of view that as our narrowest definition
of the money supply
now let's say another definition let's
call this m1
m1 and i'm running out of time
and that is how much money do people
think they have in terms of their
checking accounts in terms of their
checking accounts well the farmers think
that they have a thousand gold pieces
the original ditch construction workers
think they have 900 and then the factory
builders think they have eight hundred
and ten right so if you add them this
was one thousand plus nine hundred plus
eight hundred and ten let's see that's
nineteen hundred
that what is that twenty seven ten
twenty seven ten gold pieces
so if you asked if you went and surveyed
everyone in the city and you said how
much do you keep in your checking
accounts or how much do you have on
demand deposits in a bank
if you added up all of those numbers you
would have 210 to
2710 gold pieces if i added my numbers
correctly
this is the multiplier effect and this
happens whenever you have a fractional
reserve system and this is what people
say when when they talk about the money
supply it depends how you measure and
this is what people talk about when they
talk about money being created we had a
thousand gold coins but because of this
multiplier effect people think that
there are 2
710 gold pieces in the next video i'll
address the issue of whether they are
correct to think this see you soon